हेलो एवरीवन एंड फर्स्ट ऑफ ऑल वेरी गुड
इवनिंग टू ऑल। तो सबसे पहले मुझे यह बताइए
कि सबको मेरी आवाज सुनाई दे रही है।
आई एम ऑडिबल एवरीवन लाउड एंड क्लियर।
प्लीज जल्दी से चैट में बताइए।
आप सबको मेरी आवाज सुनाई दे रही है?
ओके वेरी गुड तो कैसे हो आप सब लोग?
मैंने आप लोगों से कल एक चीज पूछी थी।
आपने अगर रिकॉर्डिंग भी देखी हो और क्लास
के बिल्कुल स्टार्टिंग में पूछा था। आपसे
एक फीडबैक मांगा था। किसी ने भी जो लाइव
क्लास में तीन स्टूडेंट के अलावा किसी ने
फीडबैक नहीं दिया मेरे को। यह अच्छी बात
नहीं है आप लोगों की।
मैंने आप लोगों से एक फीडबैक मांगा था।
सरकार 1641
आपकी जो शौक की क्लासेस है मंडे टू
फ्राइडे के बीच में होती हैं। सैटरडे संडे
डीएई के लिए बुक रहता है। तो डीएचई की
क्लास सैटरडे और संडे को होती है। उसके
अलावा मंडे टू फ्राइडे के बीच में शौक की
क्लासेस होती हैं जो नितेश सर लेते हैं।
तो वह मंडे टू फ्राइडे के बीच में आपकी
क्लास को लेंगे। सैटरडे संडे को छोड़ के
बाकी डेज उनके लिए रिजर्व किए हुए हैं अभी
तक और सैटरडे संडे मेरे लिए हैं अभी
जी शॉक की क्लासेस आपकी फ्रीक्वेंसी के
साथ आ रही हैं और ट्राई कर रहे हैं सर भी
कोई प्रॉब्लम नहीं है आपकी काफी अच्छी
फ्रीक्वेंसी है शॉक की क्लासेस की और ऐसी
फ्रीक्वेंसी हम इसके साथ भी मेंटेन करने
की कोशिश कर रहे हैं। हो जाएगी तो हमारी
जो कौन सी जो डीएजी की सीरीज है। ओके तो
चलिए फिर स्टूडेंट्स मुझे पता है इससे
ज्यादा नहीं आने वाले क्योंकि
आई नो कि कितने स्टूडेंट्स आते हैं, कितने
नहीं आते? नहीं आने वाले।
तो किसी प्रीवियस क्लास से रिलेटेड कोई
डाउट है?
प्रीवियस क्लास से रिलेटेड कोई मुझसे कुछ
पूछना चाहता है, कोई डाउट है, कोई सवाल है
या क्लास स्टार्ट करें? बताओ फिर।
बट आई एम वेरी डिसपॉइंटंटेड फ्रॉम यू
गाइस। खास करके जो रिकॉर्डिंग देखते हैं
कि आप लोगों ने मेरे को फीडबैक नहीं दिया।
मैं आप लोगों से एक फीडबैक मांगा था
रिगार्डिंग टू द प्रेजेंटेशन।
उन्होंने वह फीडबैक नहीं दिया।
चलिए फिर
आपने अगर छह एपिसोड देखे हैं डीएसी सीरीज
के तो आपको कंटिन्यू भी करने चाहिए और साथ
के साथ यह जो टॉपिक हैं यह डिपेंड
डिपेंडेंट है उन टॉपिक के ऊपर बट आपको
एक्चुअली शो होना चाहिए उनकी नॉलेज होनी
चाहिए तो जैसेजैसे टाइम मिलता जाए आपको
पढ़ना चाहिए
ओके। तो चलिए फिर हम सेशन को स्टार्ट करते
हैं एक नई फ्रीक्वेंसी के साथ। तो चलिए
तो इफ यू रिमेंबर प्रीवियस क्लास में हमने
एक टॉपिक स्टार्ट किया था एथिकल एंड लीगल
कंसीडरेशंस इन सोशल इंजीनियरिंग। यह टॉपिक
हमने स्टार्ट किया था। तो इस टॉपिक में
हमने क्या-क्या डिस्कस किया था कल की
क्लास में? मैं आपको बता देता हूं। और एक
बार मैं अपना पेन ले लेता हूं। इसमें दिस
इज़ माय पेन। हमने सबसे पहले डिस्कस किया
था कि जो किसी भी एक पेंटस्ट की लीगल
रिस्पांसिबिलिटीज क्या होती हैं? मतलब कि
उसको क्या-क्या पता होना चाहिए? एक तो
अपनी कंट्री के साइबर लॉ के बारे में पता
होना चाहिए। डाटा लॉ के बारे में पता होना
चाहिए। प्राइवेसी लॉ के बारे में पता होना
चाहिए। फिर कंपनी के अंदर जो लॉ फॉलो होते
हैं या कंपनी के जो रूल्स रेगुलेशंस है या
कंपनी जिस एरिया में ऑपरेट करती है या
कंपनी जिस कंट्री में ऑपरेट करती है वहां
के लॉ उनको आपको पता होना चाहिए साथ फिर
आपको
उस कंट्री के लॉ भी पता होने चाहिए
बेसिकली मतलब आप जिस भी जगह पर पेन
टेस्टिंग परफॉर्म कर रहे हो उस जगह से आप
फमिलियर होने चाहिए और वहां के लॉज़ वहां
के जो लीगल लीगल
जो आपको बचा सकते हैं जो जिसको हम हिंदी
में बोले थे कानून वहां का कानून आपको पता
होना चाहिए। उसके बाद लीगली और एथिकली
सोशल इंजीनियरिंग कैसे परफॉर्म करते हैं
ये चीज मैं आपको बता चुका हूं। मैंने आपको
बताया था कि कैसे परफॉर्म करते हैं लीगली
और एथिकली। ठीक है? उसके बाद हमने जो
लास्ट
टू सेकंड लास्ट हमने जो डिस्कशन किया था
वो किया था इस्टैब्लिशिंग बाउंड्रीज इन
सोशल इंजीनियरिंग कि सोशल इंजीनियरिंग में
हमें अपनी बाउंड्रीज को से कैसे सेट करना
है। मैंने तीन बाउंड्रीज बताई थी। एक
बताया था कि अगर ड्यूरिंग सोशल
इंजीनियरिंग अगर आप किसी क्लाइंट को
विशिंग या कोई टेक्निक्स
ट्राई कर रहे हो उस टेक्निक में अगर
एंप्लई आपकी कॉल कट कर देता है। आपको
इंफॉर्मेशन देने से मना कर देता है। आपको
उस एंप्लई को दोबारा टारगेट नहीं करना है।
उसको परेशान नहीं करना है। उसके पास कॉल
अगेन नहीं करना है। ठीक है? दोबारा उसको
कॉल नहीं करना है। यह बताया था। दूसरी चीज
मैंने आपको बताई थी कि फिर आपको
जो पब्लिक प्रोफाइल है और जो उनकी
प्राइवेट प्रोफाइल है दोनों सेपरेट रखनी
है। उनकी प्राइवेट इंफॉर्मेशन आपको गैदर
नहीं करनी है। ओनली आपको पब्लिक
इंफॉर्मेशन से मतलब होना चाहिए। तो ऐसी
कुछ चीजें हमने डिस्कस की थी कल की क्लास
में। अगर आपने कल की क्लास नहीं देखी है
तो वो क्लास आपको कंटिन्यू करनी चाहिए।
उसके बाद हमने लीगल कंसीडरेशंस के बारे
में बात की थी। लीगल कंसीडरेशंस में हमने
बात की थी कि आपको जो कंपनी के जो एसेट्स
हैं जो जितने भी कंपनी के डिवाइसेस है आप
उन्हीं के ऊपर सोशल इंजीनियरिंग परफॉर्म
कर सकते हो। लेकिन उनके जो पर्सनल
डिवाइसेस होते हैं किसी भी एक एंप्लई के
जैसे उसका पर्सनल लैपटॉप है, पर्सनल
मोबाइल है या पर्सनल वाई-फाई होम नेटवर्क
है तो आप उसको टारगेट नहीं कर सकते। वो
आउट ऑफ स्कोप होता है। दूसरी चीज हमने बात
की थी कि स्पुफिंग क्या होता है? स्पुफिंग
बहुत सारी कंट्रीज में बैन होती है। तो
अगर आपके पास एक लीगल अथॉरिटी है, आपके
पास ऑथराइजेशन है तो जो आपके स्कोप में
है, जो आपके रूल्स ऑफ इंगेजमेंट में है,
वही आपको क्या करना है? लीगली परफॉर्म
करना है। वहीं पर आप उन्हीं डिवाइसेस के
ऊपर स्कोपिंग परफॉर्म कर सकते हो।
रिकॉर्डिंग की बात मैंने आपको बताई थी।
रिकॉर्डिंग कर सकते हो नहीं कर सकते हो।
इट इज वेरी फ्रॉम स्टेट टू स्टेट, कंट्री
टू कंट्री एंड स्पेसिफिक रीजन टू रीजन और
सिंगल वे टू वे मतलब आपको कंसेंट चाहिए
होता है। कंसेंट सिंगल वे भी हो सकता है।
टू वे भी हो सकता है। मिक्स भी हो सकता
है। उनका लोकल रूल्स भी होता है। तो यह
पहले यह सारी चीजें आपको पता करनी है।
इसके बीच में आपको जो लीगल काउंसिल्स हैं
उनका सहारा लेना है। उनकी हेल्प से आपको
प्रॉपर ऑथराइजेशन साइन करना है। क्या कर
सकते हो, क्या नहीं कर सकते। यह सारी
चीजें पता करनी है आपको। देन ओनली आपको यह
दोनों चीजें ट्राई करनी है। खास करके
रिकॉर्डिंग की बात है। क्योंकि रिकॉर्डिंग
करना इट इज अ वेरी वेरी
सेंसिटिव मेटल्स। तो ये चार चीजें हम
डिस्कस कर चुके थे। तो हमारा पेंडिंग क्या
है? आज आज हम डिस्कस करेंगे सर्विस
कंसीडरेशन एंड टर्म्स ऑफ यूजेज के बारे
में। नेक्स्ट हम डिस्कस करेंगे डी
ब्रीफिंग आफ्टर द इंगेजमेंट मैनेजमेंट
रिस्पांसिबिलिटीज। एक रियल वर्ल्ड केस
स्टडी यहां पर और एक इनके बीच में भी एक
टोटल यहां पर हम दो केस स्टडीज डिस्कस
करने वाले हैं जो रियल अटैक्स हो रखे हैं।
एक 2019 में हो रखा है। उसके सरकमस्ट्ससेस
हम डिस्कस करने वाले हैं। दूसरा एक 2012
में इट इज़ अ वेरी सीिवियर इंसिडेंट जो हम
डिस्कस करने वाले हैं सबसे एंड ऑफ द क्लास
में। यह दोनों ही सोशल इंजीनियरिंग के एक
परफेक्ट एग्जांपल हैं और एक डायरेक्टली
इनडायरेक्टली यह सोशल इंजीनियरिंग ही है।
तो इनके सरकमस्ट्ससेस इनके सीिवियरिटी आप
देख पाओगे कि क्या थी वो रियल रियल केस
स्टडीज। ओके हां गुड इवनिंग एवरीवन। गुड
इवनिंग एंड जहां पर गुड मॉर्निंग है वहां
पर गुड मॉर्निंग। गुड मॉर्निंग एंड गुड
इवनिंग एवरीवन।
नेक्स्ट अब हम बात करने वाले हैं किस में?
सर्विस कंसीडरेशन एंड टर्म्स ऑफ यूज़। ठीक
है? तो
अब हम आते हैं आपके नेक्स्ट पॉइंट पर। दैट
इज आवर सर्विस कंसीडरेशंस एंड टर्म्स ऑफ
यूज़। मतलब यह वह पॉइंट है जहां पर बहुत से
हैकर्स या यहां तक कि जो प्रोफेशनल
पेंटेस्टर्स होते हैं वह भी इसको अक्सर
इग्नोर कर देते हैं। किसको? टर्म्स ऑफ यूज़
जिसको हम बोल सकते हैं टी ओ एस। टर्म्स ऑफ
यूज़ क्या होता है? यह आपको पता चल जाएगा।
ठीक है? मतलब बहुत सारे हैकर्स या इवन
बहुत सारे प्रोफेशंस भी होते हैं जो इसको
इग्नोर करते हैं ड्यूरिंग टेस्टिंग। ठीक
है? तो मतलब क्या है? मतलब यह है कि आप
जिस भी प्लेटफार्म का यूज कर रहे हो अटैक
करते वक्त अगर आपने उसके टर्म्स को वायलेट
किया उसके जो भी टर्म्स एंड कंडीशंस थी
अगर उनको वायलेट किया उनको फॉलो नहीं किया
तो आपको लेने के देने पड़ सकते हैं। मतलब
मतलब यह है फॉर एग्जांपल जब भी आप किसी भी
कंपनी के लिए पेन टेस्टिंग करते हो किसी
भी कंपनी के लिए सिक्योरिटी टेस्टिंग करते
हो खासकर की सोशल इंजीनियरिंग की बात करते
हैं तो हर एक कंपनी बहुत सारी थर्ड पार्टी
सर्विज का यूज़ करती है जैसे कि Microsoft
365 हो गया Google वर्कस्पेस हो गया स्लक
हो गया ZM हो गया octa हो गया शेयर पॉइंट
हो गया nसन ऐसी बहुत सारी थर्ड पार्टी
सर्विज है जिनका यूज किया जाता है हर एक
सर्विज की अपनी टर्म्स ऑफ सर्विस होती
हैं। हर एक सर्विज की अपनी टर्म्स एंड
कंडीशंस होती है। क्या करना है, क्या नहीं
करना है, क्या आप कर सकते हो, कितना कर
सकते हो? क्या आपके लेवल है? मतलब इससे
ज्यादा आप इंफॉर्मेशन कलेक्ट नहीं कर
सकते। इससे ज्यादा इंफॉर्मेशन आपके पास
नहीं होनी चाहिए। या इतना ही एक्सेस कर
सकते हो, इतना एक्सेस नहीं कर सकते। कितना
यूज़ कर सकते हो, इतना मिसयूज नहीं कर
सकते। मतलब उसकी पॉलिसीज, उसकी टर्म्स ऑफ
कंडीशंस या टर्म्स ऑफ सर्विस। यह सारी
चीजें हर एक सर्विज की अपनी टर्म्स एंड
सर्विस होती है। और जब एक कंपनी है और
कंपनी जब थर्ड पार्टी सर्विज को यूज़ करती
है तो वह कंपनी पर उसके टर्म्स ऑफ सर्विज
भी क्या होती है? लागू होती हैं। ओके? वो
टर्म्स ऑफ सर्विज लागू होती हैं। तो अभी
आप क्या है कि आप नॉर्मल आपने ऑथराइजेशन
ले लिया। नॉर्मल आपने ऑथराइजेशन ले लिया
तो इसका मतलब यह नहीं है कि आपने अगर
ऑथराइजेशन ले लिया तो आप
इनको भी क्या कर सकते हो? टेस्ट कर सकते
हो या फिर इनको भी अटैक कर सकते हो या
इनको भी यूज कर सकते हो। ठीक है? मतलब कर
सकते हो। ऐसा नहीं कि आप यूज़ नहीं कर
सकते। यूज़ कर सकते हो। बट विद इन देयर
स्कोप जो इनकी टर्म्स ऑफ सर्विस है वही
फॉलो करते हुए आप क्या कर सकते हो? इनको
यूज़ कर सकते हो। अगर उनको वायलेट करोगे आप
तो फिर उसके जो नेगेटिव सरकमस्ट्ससेस
होंगे उसके जो नेगेटिव इंपैक्ट होंगे उसके
लिए भी आपको रेडी होना पड़ेगा। ठीक है?
इसलिए
आपका जो लीगल कॉन्ट्रैक्ट है कंपनी के साथ
ठीक है? वो कंपनी के साथ है ना कि इन
प्लेटफार्म के साथ। वह लीगल कॉन्ट्रैक्ट
जिसकी मैं बात कर रहा हूं यहां पर यह आपकी
कंपनी के साथ है ना कि आपकी इन प्लेटफार्म
के साथ। यह चीज आपको ध्यान में रखनी है।
चलो इसको समझाने के लिए मैं आपको एक रियल
वर्ल्ड इंसिडेंट शेयर करता हूं जिसकी मैं
बात कर रहा था अभी। एक रियल वर्ल्ड
इंसिडेंट क्या है कि 2019 में 2019 की बात
है। ठीक है? तो ये इंसिडेंट आपको Google
पे मिल जाएगा। ये रहा यहां पर ये है। 2019
में एक कहां की बात है ये? ब्लैक हिल
इंफॉर्मेशन सिक्योरिटी है। उस उसमें एक
बहुत ही ब्रिलियंट आपके बोले कि एक
सिक्योरिटी एनालिस्ट थे जिनका नाम था माइक
फेल्स। ठीक है? यह इन्होंने अपने ब्लॉग
में लिखा है कि हाउ टू परच Google एंड
स्टार्ट ओवर पार्ट वन और पार्ट टू दो इसके
पार्ट है। तो इनकी इन्होंने काफी डिटेल्स
में रिपोर्ट लिखी है। तो मैं इसको एक
समराइज करता हूं। इसका ओवरव्यू देता हूं
कि एक्चुअल में क्या-क्या हुआ था। ठीक है?
क्या-क्या नहीं हुआ था। इन्होंने क्या है?
कहीं पे पन टेस्टिंग की उसकी एक रियल
वर्ल्ड केस है। तो मैं इसको आपके साथ शेयर
कर रहा हूं ताकि आप इसको अपने खुद के टाइम
जब आपको टाइम मिले तो आप इसको पढ़ लें।
चलिए तो ये चीज आपके पास मैंने शेयर कर
दी। तो हुआ क्या था कि जब ये पेन टेस्टिंग
कर रहे थे। ये पेन टेस्टिंग कर रहे थे।
ऑथराइज पेन टेस्टिंग। ऐसे नहीं कि ऐसे ही
कुछ कर रहे यह पेन टेस्टिंग ऑथराइज पेन
टेस्टिंग कर रहे थे। इनके पास अथॉरिटी थी।
यह पेन टेस्टिंग कर रहे थे। ड्यूरिंग पेन
टेस्टिंग इन्होंने क्या किया? इन्होंने
यूज़ किया Google वर्कस्पेस को। मतलब उस
टाइम पे जीसूट बोलते थे। ठीक है? जिसको हम
आज Google वर्कस्पेस बोलते हैं। इन्होंने
इसका क्या है? यूज़ किया। ठीक है? इसको
टारगेट किया। और सबसे मजे की बात क्या है
ना? टारगेट तो किया ही किया। इसको अपना
अटैक टूल भी बना लिया। टारगेट के साथ-साथ
इसको अपना अटैक टूल भी बना लिया। जो
Google वर्कस्पेस है इसको अपना अटैक टूल
भी बना लिया। इसको एज ए अटैक टूल भी यूज़
किया। तो अभी
अटैक टूल यूज़ किया तो इन्होंने क्या किया?
इसके थ्रू इन्होंने जो क्रेडेंशियल थे
उनको सक्सेसफुली कॉम्प्रोमाइज कर लिया। जो
क्रेडेंशियल थे उनको सक्सेसफुली
कॉम्प्रोमाइज कर लिया। कॉम्प्रोमाइज करने
के बाद इन्होंने क्या किया? एक टूल था
क्रेड स्नाइपर। कभी सुना होगा सी आर ई डी
क्रेड स्नाइपर यह रहा क्रेड स्नाइपर एक
टूल टूल होता है ठीक है
यह रहा एक ये क्रेड स्नाइपर टूल है इसने
क्या किया इसकी हेल्प से ठीक है और जी शूट
को यूज़ करते हुए मल्टीफैक्टर ऑथेंटिकेशन
बाईपास कर लिया मल्टीफैक्टर ऑथेंटिकेशन को
क्या कर लिया बायपास कर लिया एमएफ पे
बायपास हो गया और यहां तक सब कुछ चल रहा
था परफेक्ट सब कुछ सही चल रहा था यहां तक
यहां तक चल यहां तक सब कुछ चल रहा था सही
भाई कोई दिक्कत नहीं थी सब सही चल रहा था
इधर तक कोई दिक्कत नहीं थी दिक्कत कहां पर
स्टार्ट हुई जब यह टेस्टिंग हो रही थी
ड्यूल डिटेक्शन हो गया ड्यूल डिटेक्शन
क्या है एक तो जो क्लाइंट की शॉक टीम थी
क्लाइंट के जो सिक्योरिटी ऑपरेशन टीम थी
उसने इन्हें डिटेक्ट कर लिया
और सबसे बड़ी डेंजरस चीज जो सबसे खतरनाक
चीज हुई कि जो Google का जो Google की जो
शॉक टीम थी जो खुद की जो ऑटो हम एआई
ड्रिवन टीम बोल सकते हैं एआई डिटेक्शन एआई
के द्वारा ड्राइव की हुई शॉक एंड शॉक टीम
या जो ऑटोमेटिक एल्गोरििदम काम कर रही थी
डिटेक्शन एल्गोरिदम काम करी थी जिस शॉक के
अंदर उन्होंने भी क्या कर लिया इसको
डिटेक्ट कर लिया क्लाइंट ने डिटेक्ट किया
ही किया Google ने भी इसको डिटेक्ट कर
लिया कि इस मिलिशियस एक्टिविटी को कैच कर
लिया अब Google ने क्या किया? वह सुनकर
आपके होश उड़ जाएंगे। Google ने क्या
किया? Google ने क्या किया कि
जिस टेंपरेरी अकाउंट से वो अटैक हो रहा
था। ठीक है? उसको तो ब्लॉक किया ही किया।
साथ के साथ Google की जो ऑटोमेटिक
एल्गोरििदम थी जो डिटेक्शन परफॉर्म कर रही
थी। उस एल्गोरिदम ने ओपन सोर्स इंटेलिजेंस
परफॉर्म किया। उस एल्गोरिदम में ओसेंट
परफॉर्म किया और ओसेंट से उसने आइडेंटिफाई
किया कि
यह कहां से यह बैंडविड्थ यूज़ हो रही है।
ठीक है? यह एक्टिविटी कौन से एरिया से हो
रही है? कहां से यह एक्टिविटी परफॉर्म की
जा रही है? जहां से एक्टिविटी ये परफॉर्म
की जाती है, वहां की बैंडविड्थ को एनालाइज
किया। एनालाइज करके उसने क्या किया?
सोच रहे हो? क्या किया? जो माइक था जिसकी
हम बात कर रहे हैं माइक। उसका जो पर्सनल
अकाउंट था एक तो टेस्टिंग अकाउंट तो अलग
था ही था ही उसका जो पर्सनल अकाउंट था
उसके जो अनरिलेटेड Google अकाउंट थे ठीक
है उसका पर्सनल अकाउंट हो गया इवन जो उसके
फैमिली उसकी जो वाइफ का जो पर्सनल अकाउंट
था उसके फैमिली मेंबर्स के पर्सनल अकाउंट
थे इवन क्या हुआ उसके घर पर वो क्या कर
रहे थे एक ऑटोमेट ऑटोमेशन सिस्टम यूज़ कर
रहे थे जो Google से कनेक्टेड था ठीक है
जिसका नाम था
थर्मोस्टेट थर्मोस्टेट जिसका काम था
ऑटोमेटिकली टेंपरेचर कंट्रोल करना जो
Google से कनेक्टेड था इन सबको कर दिया
ब्लॉक इन सबको क्या कर दिया उसने ब्लॉक कर
दिया समझ में आई बात इन सबको ब्लॉक कर
दिया मतलब सोच रहे हो कि कितने खतरनाक चीज
की सारे पर्सनल अकाउंट फैमिली के पर्सनल
अकाउंट जो अनलिटेड Google अकाउंट्स इवन जो
ऑटोमेटिक
जो होम स्मार्ट डिवाइसेस थे जो Google से
कनेक्टेड थे उनके उनके अकाउंट ब्लॉक सब
कुछ उसने क्या कर दिया? ब्लॉक कर दिया।
मतलब घर में जो ऑटोमेटिक टेंपरेचर कंट्रोल
होता था वो भी इनके हाथ में नहीं था। मतलब
एक छोटी सी चेन रिएक्शन स्टार्ट हुई। उस
चेन रिएक्शन के से सब कुछ इनका हो गया
ब्लॉक।
सब कुछ हो गया ब्लॉक। जस्ट इमेजिन कि एक
प्रोफेशनल टेस्टिंग की वजह से उनकी पर्सनल
लाइफ फ्रीज हो गई।
ठीक? कर तो प्रोफेशनल टेस्टिंग रहे थे।
ऑथराइज फेंटेस्टिंग कर रहे थे ना वे बट
क्या हुआ उनकी जो पर्सनल जो लाइफ थी पूरी
की पूरी फ्रीज हो गई
पूरी की पूरी फ्रीज हो गई समझ में आया कि
क्या हुआ
कि उन्होंने किसको यूज़ किया अटैक के लिए
एक थर्ड पार्टी सर्विस को यूज किया थर्ड
पार्टी क्लाउड सर्विस को और जो थर्ड
पार्टी क्लाउड सर्विस थी थी उनके टर्म्स
और जो टीओ एस थी टर्म्स ऑफ सर्विस थी वो
वायलेट हो हो गई। उनको फॉलो नहीं किया।
वहां की जो डिटेक्शन टीम ने उसको डिटेक्ट
कर लिया। डिटेक्ट करने के बाद उन्हें सब
कुछ ब्लॉक कर दिया। उन्होंने सब कुछ ब्लॉक
कर दिया। यह था इसका हाई लेवल ऑफ ओवरव्यू।
बाकी आपको डिटेल रिपोर्ट देखनी है जो
इन्होंने अपने ब्लॉग में लिखी है। उसके दो
पार्ट हैं। उसको मैंने अभी शेयर किया है
आपके सामने। उसमें पढ़ लीजिए। ठीक है?
उसमें काफी डिटेल रिपोर्ट लिखी हुई है।
क्या कैसे क्या-क्या किया, क्या-क्या हुआ,
सब कुछ उसमें लिखा हुआ है। यह था आपका हाई
लेवल ओवरव्यू। तो, इस पूरी कहानी का
हमें
मोराल क्या मिलता है? इस कहानी से हमें
सीख क्या मिलती है? कि एज एन एथिकल हैकर
आपकी रिस्पांसिबिलिटी सिर्फ क्लाइंट के
सर्वर को देखना नहीं है। कोई भी इंगेजमेंट
शुरू करने से पहले आपको क्या करना है?
क्लाइंट की जितनी भी थर्ड पार्टी सर्विस
प्रोवाइडर्स है चाहे वह Google हो
Microsoft हो AWS हो उनके साथ आपको क्या
करना है एक प्रॉपर कोऑर्डिनेशन
कोऑर्डिनेशन करना है उनको नोट नोटिफाई
करना है उनको नोटिफिकेशन भेजना है उनको
बताना है कि आप ऐसेसे एक्टिविटी टेस्टिंग
कर रहे हो एग्जैक्ट हावर्स एग्जैक्ट डेट
नहीं बताने की जरूरत है लेकिन अपने आपको
वाइट लिस्ट करवाना है ठीक है पता चला
क्लाइंट की टेस्टिंग तो बाद में होगी
ठीक है? इंगेजमेंट के चक्कर में आपको अपनी
पर्सनल लाइफ को पहले ब्लॉक करवा लिया। ठीक
है? इंगेजमेंट के चक्कर में आपने अपनी
पर्सनल लाइफ को ही ब्लॉक करवा लिया।
इसीलिए कहते हैं कि जो भी एथिक्स होते
हैं, जो भी रूल्स होते हैं, सिर्फ वो
टारगेट पे अप्लाई नहीं होते। वो पूरे
एनवायरमेंट के लिए भी होते हैं। हमें ऐसा
लगता है कि एथिक्स और जो रूल्स हैं सिर्फ
उन्हीं के लिए ऐसा नहीं है। रूल्स सबके
लिए होते हैं। किसी के लिए ज्यादा, किसी
के लिए कम। ठीक है? आप किसी भी चीज के नाम
से अपने आप को हाइड नहीं कर सकते। मतलब
आपको रूल के हिसाब से ही चलना पड़ेगा। अगर
वहीं पर इस रिपोर्ट के अकॉर्डिंग उन्होंने
अगर उनको
वहां पर अपने आप को वाइड लिस्टेड करवाया
होता तो यह जो फाइव स्टेप नंबर फाइव,
स्टेप नंबर सिक्स और स्टेप नंबर जो सेवन
होगी ना, यह होते ही नहीं। उनकी पर्सनल
लाइफ हार्म ही नहीं होती। तो, यह एक
एग्जांपल्स है सोशल इंजीनियरिंग का। यह
एग्जांपल्स है उन रूल्स का, उन एथिक्स का
जो आपको हमेशा ध्यान में रखने हैं जो आपको
हमेशा ध्यान में रखने हैं। मैं आपके सामने
एक इमेज शो कर रहा हूं डूज और डोंट। ठीक
है?
यहां पर एक लिखा है जो क्लाइंट ऑथराइजेशन
है इज नॉट इक्वल टू टर्म्स ऑफ सर्विस। ठीक
है? ए क्लाइंट कॉन्ट्रैक्ट डज नॉट ओवराइड
और रिप्लेस द इंडिपेंडेंट टर्म्स ऑफ
सर्विस ऑफ थर्ड पार्टी प्लेटफार्म। अगर
आपके पास क्लाइंट का ऑथराइजेशन है इसका
मतलब नहीं है कि जो थर्ड पार्टी सर्विज है
उसकी जो टर्म्स ऑफ सर्विज को वह ओवराइड कर
देगा। नहीं वो सिर्फ उस पर्टिकुलर कंपनी
उस पर्टिकुलर ऑर्गेनाइजेशन के लिए है। वो
किसी भी थर्ड पार्टी सर्विज की को ओवराइड
नहीं करता। वह ऑथराइजेशन वो ओवराइड करवाने
के लिए आपको उन्हीं से ही बात करनी
पड़ेगी। उनका ऑथराइजेशन चाहिए। उनके साथ
आपको मिलजुलकर काम करना पड़ेगा। अदरवाइज
जो सरकमस्ट्ससेस आपने अभी देखे हैं, सेम
सरकमस्ट्ससेस आपको भी देखने को मिल सकते
हैं। आपका अकाउंट लॉक, अकाउंट सस्पेंड
उसके बाद घूमते रहो।
दीज़ आर द डूज और डोंट। समझ में आई कहानी?
थोड़ी रियलिटी लगी आपको?
अगर आपको वीएपीटी ही करना है टैग डाई देखो
हमारी जो सीरीज है धीरे-धीरे आगे बढ़ रही
है समय लगेगा समय कम है डेफोनिक्स का
वीएपीटी कोर्स चलता है ठीक है वह ज्वाइन
कर लो फुल दो से तीन महीने की ट्रेनिंग है
फुल जॉब ओरिएंटेड कोर्स है आप उसको ज्वाइन
कर सकते हो
एवरीवन अंडरस्टुड
देखा कि एथिक्स और रूल्स ना फॉलो करने का
नतीजा।
डड यू थिंक अबाउट इट? इससे पहले कभी आपने
इसके बारे में सोचा है?
मेरे भाइयों सबसे पहले मैं आपको एक चीज
बता देता हूं। चलो मैं आपका सवाल का जवाब
दे देता हूं। चलो मैं आता हूं। आपके सवाल
पर आता हूं। उसके बाद हम कंटिन्यू करते
हैं। आपका सवाल है सर कि डीईए या बग बंटी।
डीएई एक पेन टेस्टिंग सीरीज है।
एंटरप्राइज लेवल पेन टेस्टिंग सीरीज
इंडस्ट्री लेवल पेन टेस्टिंग सीरीज। जैसे
इंडस्ट्री में एक्चुअल में पेन टेस्टिंग
होती है। उसी तरीके से पेन टेस्टिंग आपको
सिखाने की कोशिश कर रहा हूं। उसी तरीके से
सिनेरियोस उस तरीके से लीगल एथिक्स उसी
तरह की पेन टेस्टिंग आपको सिखाने की कोशिश
बग बंटी एक सेपरेट डोमेन है बग बंटी ओनली
स्पेसिफिक टू वेब वनेबिलिटीज
ठीक है बस वेब की भी आप उसमें सारी
वनेबिलिटी मास्टर में नहीं होती है
पेंटेस्टिंग एक बहुत बड़ा स्कोप होता है
बहुत बड़ा डोमेन होता है
ठीक है बहुत बड़ा डोमेन होता है इसलिए बग
बंटी और डी जो पें टेस्टिंग में बहुत अंतर
होता है यह डीईए क्या है आपकी पेन
टेस्टिंग सीरीज है पेट्रेशन टेस्टिंग
जिसमें सारी सब कुछ आता है वेब भी आता है
पेन टेस्टिंग के अंदर मैं आपको जनरल है
डीएचई की बात नहीं बात कर मैं बात कर रहा
हूं कि
आपकी पेन टेस्टिंग की पेन टेस्टिंग में
आपकी वेब भी आता है वाईफाई भी आता है सोशल
इंजीनिंग भी आता है। सब कुछ आता है पेन
टेस्टिंग में और पेन टेस्टिंग एक छोटा सा
पार्ट जिसको आप बग बंटी नाम देते हो दैट
इज सेपरेट थिंग बग बंटी सिर्फ आप बोल सकते
हो कि ओनली वेब स्पेसिफिक वेब वबिलिटीज को
फाइंड आउट करना वो भी अपने टाइम में बट
आपको सच में कुछ रियल नॉलेज गेन करनी है।
लाइफ में फन चाहिए आपको लगता है कि मुझे
बस
सच में यही मेरा डोमेन है। मुझे इसी में
फोड़ना है कुछ ना कुछ और मुझे मास्टर बनना
है। मुझे सब कुछ सीखना है। तो अकेले बग
बाउंट से कुछ नहीं कर सकते। सच रियलिटी है
यह। आपको पेन टेस्टिंग सीखनी चाहिए। पेन
टेस्टिंग में सब कुछ कवर होता है। लनस को
हैक करना, विंडोज को हैक करना, उनके अंदर
सेल गेन करना, पोस्ट एक्सप्लइटेशन,
एक्सप्लइटेशन
की बात उसके बाद फायर वाल बायपास करना,
इवेज करना बहुत कुछ होता है। यह सब
पटेस्टिंग में होता है। पेंटेस्टिंग बहुत
ज्यादा इंटरेस्टिंग होता है। इट इज अ टाइम
टेकिंग ट्रेनिंग। बहुत सारा समय लगता है
इसमें। इट इज़ वेरी वेरी इंटरेस्टेड एंड
काफी स्पेसिफिक होती है अगर आप वो सीखते
हो तो।
ठीक है?
अंडरस्टुड एवरीवन? यह बहुत बड़ा डिफरेंस
होता है। लोग एक ही चीज समझ लेते हैं। एक
चीज नहीं होती। पेंटेस्टिंग और बग बाउंट
इज अ सेपरेट पेंटेस्टिंग। बग बंटी
पेंटेस्टिंग का डोमेन हो सकता है। लेकिन
बग बाउंटी को आप पेंटेस्टिंग नहीं बोल
सकते।
ऐसे तो मेरे भाई कार्बन 7738 सब कुछ
ऑटोमेट हो जाओगे तो पढ़ना छोड़ दोगे।
ऐसे तो आपको फिर तो चैट जीपीटी Google सब
कुछ प्रोवाइड कर देता है। आपको अपने
मास्टर्स नहीं करने चाहिए। आपको अपनी
ग्रेजुएशनंस नहीं करनी चाहिए। आपको अपने
12th की स्टडी नहीं करने चाहिए। क्योंकि
कट कॉपी पेस्ट करके तो आपको पता ही होगा।
सब कुछ हो जाएगा तो यह करने ही नहीं
चाहिए।
आई एम राइट एवरीवन नहीं करने चाहिए ना?
बताओ नहीं करने चाहिए। क्या करोगे करके
फिर
बट ऐसा नहीं है ना?
किसी को नहीं पता क्या होगा।
अडॉप अप्शन टेक्नोलॉजी जब भी कोई नई
टेक्नोलॉजी आती है मार्केट में हम सब डरते
हैं। उसको समय देना चाहिए। उससे डरना नहीं
चाहिए। उसको अडॉप करना है तो हमें उसी के
हिसाब से उसको अडॉप करेंगे।
टेक्नोलॉजी नई होती है। हाला होता है
मार्केट में। धीरे-धीरे पुरानी होगी तो उस
हिसाब से
पता भी चल जाएगा।
डरना नहीं है उस चीज से। आपको अडॉप करना
सीखना है उसको। वो टेक्नोलॉजी का यूज़ करना
सीखो। फिर
चलिए फिर स्टार्ट करें। कंटिन्यू। यहां तक
कोई सवाल है किसी का?
यहां तक किसी का कोई सवाल है? एनीवन हैव
एनी डाउट्स?
तो कंपनियां ऐसा कर रही हैं तो उसका भी
मैं आपको बता देता हूं। फंडामेंटल सीखो
कैसे होती है सीखो या जो आप मेरे को एक
सवाल का जवाब दे दीजिए। तो मैं एक चीज मान
जाऊंगा। चलो आपके सवाल पे आते हैं। मैं
क्या नाम है आपका? हां कार्बन आपका रियल
नाम मुझे नहीं पता
कि 7738 कंपनियां ऑटोमेशन यूज कर रही हैं।
सब कुछ ऑटोमेशन पर शिफ्ट हो रहा है। क्या
मुझे एक चीज बताओ ऑटोमेशंस जिसने बनाया
होगा। क्या उसने ऐसे ही बना दिया?
स्मार्ट वर्क कर रहे हैं ना बेबी। तो आप
सीखो आप एक काम करो ना बस सीखो सीख के
उनहीं के ऑटोमेशन को और स्मार्ट स्मार्टली
यूज़ करो स्मार्ट वर्क बनाओ आप भी कुछ कर
सकते हो
आपको क्या लगता है कि उधर उन्होंने ऑटोमेट
कर लिया था कुछ और चीज नई नहीं जनरेट होगी
वो भी तो टैक है ना लेकिन जो जिस जो चीज
ऑटोमेट कर रही है
वह भी तो एक मशीन है
उस मशीन के लिए फिर आपको कुछ ना कुछ तो
सीखना पड़ेगा। दी आर द बेसिक्स।
मैं कुछ ऐसी चीज तो नहीं बता रहा ना। आपको
लग रहा है कि यह चीजें हैं पुरानी है।
बट कामयाब भी यही है। ऐसा नहीं कि कामयाब
नहीं है। वेस्टेज ऑफ टाइम नहीं है। ये आप
लोगों के लिए हमेशा काम आएंगी।
बेसिक नहीं सब कुछ सीखा है जब ऑटोमेशन ऐसे
नहीं बन गया एक पूरी चीज किसी चीज को
रातोंरात ऑटोमेशन नहीं होता
ऑटोमेशन तभी हो पाया है जब उसके पास सब
कुछ डाटा है सब कुछ है कितने लोग कितने
एक्सपर्ट्स ने मिलके वो चीज की होगी
तो आपको सिर्फ सीखना है अभी देखते जाओ
मार्केट में क्या हो रहा है सीख के उसकी
उसी तरफ से डायरेक्शन लेते रहो फिर गेन
करो फिर एक दिन जब मौका मिले राइट टाइम पे
अपने आप को ज्वाइन कर लो
बिल्कुल चलिए फिर
नेक्स्ट बात करते हैं डी ब्रीफिंग आफ्टर द
इंगेजमेंट अब बात करते हैं इंगेजमेंट खत्म
होने के बाद सबसे इंपॉर्टेंट स्टेप स्टेप
होता है जिसे हम कहते हैं डी ब्रीफिंग डी
ब्रीफिंग का मतलब क्या होता है
डी ब्रीफिंग का मतलब होता है ऑर्गेनाइजेशन
और ऑर्गेनाइजेशन के अंदर काम करने वाले
एंप्लई को फेस टू फेस बैठाकर
अपने उनको क्या करना है फेस टू फेस बैठाकर
उनको बताना है कि आपने कौन सी टेक्निक का
यूज किया कौन सी कमियां आपने फाइंड आउट की
और क्या इंफॉर्मेशन आपने निकाली क्या
इंफॉर्मेशन आपने निकाली ये सारी चीज आपको
क्या करना है उन कंपनी के सीनियर्स
डायरेक्टर्स सबको क्या करना है बैठाकर
आपको क्या बताना बताना है
कि आपने कौन सी टेक्निक्स का यूज़ किया है।
प्रीक्टिंग यूज़ की, वी विशिंग यूज़ की।
क्या-क्या आपने यूज़ किया? कहां-कहां पर
आपको सिक्योरिटी गैप मिले हैं? क्या-क्या
इंफॉर्मेशन आपने कलेक्ट की है। ठीक है?
उसके बाद
कौन-कौन से डिपार्टमेंट हाईलाइट हुए हैं।
बट वो मैं बताऊंगा। उसके बाद क्या-क्या
नहीं करना था? यह आपके सिक्योरिटी लाइसेंस
है। सारी चीजें आपको क्या करनी है? डी
ब्रीफ करनी है। लेकिन यहां पर भी सबसे
बड़ा एक एथिक रूल अप्लाई होता है। एथिक
रूल क्या अप्लाई होता है आपका कि आपको
क्या नहीं करना है? आपको हमेशा ब्रॉड टर्म
में बात करनी है। इंडिविजुअल को पब्लिकली
टारगेट नहीं करना है। फॉर एग्जांपल नो
पब्लिक सेमिंग मतलब पब्लिक सेविंग नहीं
करनी है। आपको पूरी कंपनी या उनके
मैनेजमेंट के सामने जाकर यह नहीं बोलना है
कि फाइनेंस डिपार्टमेंट से राहुल शर्मा ने
पासवर्ड में अपने पत्नी का नाम यूज किया
हुआ था विद डेट ऑफ बर्थ। यह चीज आपको नहीं
बतानी है। या आपको यह नहीं बताना है कि
एचआर डिपार्टमेंट से सोनसो एंप्लॉय था।
उसके घर में प्रॉब्लम चल रही थी। उसके
अंकल बीमार थे या उसके अंकल के साथ उनका
झगड़ा चल रहा था। मैंने उसका फायदा उठाकर
उसको मैनपुलेट कर लिया। यह तरीका क्या है
आपका? इट इज हाईली अनप्रोफेशनल एंड
टॉक्सिक। कोई भी एक प्रोफेशनल सोशल
इंजीनियर कभी भी ऐसे बात नहीं करता। वह
हमेशा क्या करेगा? अपनी रिपोर्ट को एक
जनरलाइज्ड फॉर्मेट में क्या करेगा?
रिप्रेजेंट करेगा। ऐसी रिपोर्ट कभी नहीं
रिप्रेजेंट करेगा। यह वाली रिपोर्ट
जनरलाइज करेगा। कैसे? कि उसकी रिपोर्ट ऐसे
हो सकती है कि हमने नोटिस किया कि कुछ
एंप्लाइज अपनी जो फैमिली मेंबर्स या उनकी
जो पत्नियां हैं उनका नाम एज ए पासवर्ड
यूज कर रहे हैं जो एक वीक प्रैक्टिससेस
होती है या
दूसरा आप क्या बोल सकते हो कि जब उन्होंने
ओपन सोर्स इंटेलिजेंस परफॉर्म की तो उनको
पता चला जो कंपनीज हैं कंपनी कंपनी के जो
एंप्लाइज हैं वो पर्सनल रिलेशनशिप की
इंफॉर्मेशन पब्लिकली ऑनलाइन लाइन उन्होंने
रखी हुई है जिससे उनको आसानी से एक्सप्लइट
किया जा सकता है। उनका फायदा उठाया जा
सकता है। इसलिए आपको हमेशा क्या करना है?
एनोनिमस रिपोर्टिंग करनी है। एंप्लई की
प्राइवेसी को ध्यान में रखना है।
प्रोफेशनल रिपोर्टिंग करनी है। जनरलाइज
फाइंडिंग यूज़ करनी है। किसी को
इंडिविजुअली ब्लेम नहीं करना है। कभी भी
किसी को इंडिविजुअली ब्लेम नहीं करना है।
समझ में आई यह बात? किसी को भी
इंडिविजुअली ब्लेम नहीं करना है।
इंडिविजुअल ब्लेम आपको नहीं करना है।
क्योंकि एक ट्रिक मैं बताता हूं। ज्यादातर
प्रोफेशनल सोशल इंजीनियर भी करते हैं और
आप भी कर सकते हो। आपको क्या करना है कि
आपको एक प्राइवेट एक प्राइवेट रिपोर्ट
मेंटेन करनी है और एक पब्लिक प्राइवेट
रिपोर्ट में क्या है? आपके पास पूरी डिटेल
होगी। कितनी तारीख को कौन से डिपार्टमेंट
का कौन सा एंप्लॉय था? क्या इंफॉर्मेशन
पूरी डिटेल रिपोर्ट्स होगी। लेकिन जब वह
पब्लिकली मतलब जब वह रिपोर्ट सबमिट होगी
इन फाइंडिंग्स को क्या करना है आपको हटा
देना है आपको एनोनिटी मेंटेन करनी है आपको
हाइड कर देनी है आपको एक क्या करना है एक
जनरलाइज फॉर्मेट में रिपोर्ट कन्वर्ट करनी
है उसके बाद वह आपको रिप्रेजेंट करनी है
क्योंकि जो आपने रिपोर्ट मेंटेन की है वो
प्राइवेट रिपोर्ट सिर्फ आपके लिए है आपके
रेफरेंस के लिए है ना कि कंपनी के रेफरेंस
के लिए है वो क्या करनी है अब सबसे बड़ा
सवाल उठता है। सबसे बड़ा सवाल यह है क्या
क्लाइंट कंपनी के मैनेजमेंट को क्या
क्लाइंट कंपनी के मैनेजमेंट को उन
एंप्लाइज का नाम मिलना चाहिए जो इस फिशिंग
या विशिंग टेस्ट में फेल हो गए। मेरा सवाल
यह है जो सबका सवाल होगा सर कि जो
मैनेजमेंट है कंपनी का जो मैनेजमेंट स्टाफ
है जो टेस्टिंग करवा रहा है क्या उनको वह
नाम मिलने चाहिए? जो टारगेट हुए हैं, जो
आपके ट्रैप में आए हैं, जिनको आपने फिशिंग
कोल से फंसाया है, जो बकरा बने हैं, क्या
उनका नाम रिवील होना चाहिए या नहीं होना
चाहिए? देखो, अगर बात करें पॉइंट ऑफ
कांटेक्ट की या कंपनी के सीईओ की और अगर
वह आपसे आकर बोलता है कि वह आपसे नाम
मांगता है कि मुझे वह नाम दे दो
तो आप वह नाम दे सकते हो। लेकिन कुछ
कंडीशन के साथ ठीक है? वह कंडीशन कौन सी
है? वह कंडीशन है कि आपको कंपनी के
मैनेजमेंट से यह बोलना होगा कि कंपनी का
मैनेजमेंट आपसे एग्री करे। आपसे उनको
एग्री करना होगा कि पहली बात एंप्लई को
टर्मिनेट नहीं किया जाएगा। उसको फायर नहीं
किया जाएगा। उसके अगेंस्ट कोई भी
डिसिप्लिनरी एक्सेस नहीं लिया। एक ज्यादा
बड़ा डिसिप्लिनरी एक्शन नहीं लिया जाएगा।
उसके पर्सनल ग्रोथ को कुछ प्रॉब्लम नहीं
होगी। मतलब यह कंपनी को प्रॉमिस करना होगा
देन ओनली आप क्या कर सकते हो वो
इंफॉर्मेशन
लीक कर सकते मतलब वो इंफॉर्मेशन लीक नहीं
बोल सकते आप उस मैनेजमेंट के साथ शेयर कर
सकते हो उस पॉइंट ऑफ कांटेक्ट के साथ शेयर
कर सकते हो लेकिन एक सोचने की बात है कि
आप ऐसा क्यों करोगे किसी एंप्लई के लिए
क्योंकि लेकिन दूसरा यह भी सोचो ना कि वो
पॉइंट ऑफ कांटेक्ट है आपसे मांग क्यों रहा
है इंफॉर्मेशन क्योंकि उस एंप्लई का तो
फायर करेगा वह या उसकी जगह रिप्लेसमेंट
ढूंढा जाएगा या उसके पर्सनल बेनिफिट को कट
किया जाएगा। लेकिन यह चीज आपको प्रोटेक्ट
करनी है। इट इज योर जॉब बिकॉज़ आपकी वजह से
किसी की जॉब नहीं जानी चाहिए। यह कंपनी की
गलती है कि वो एंप्लॉय ट्रेंड क्यों नहीं
है? एमंप्लई की गलती नहीं है। क्या-क्या
वजह हैं कि वह एमंप्लई इंफॉर्मेशन दे पाया
या तो उसके पास प्रॉपर ट्रेनिंग नहीं थी
या फिर
सही से उसको समझाया नहीं गया। ठीक है? तो
इसीलिए कुछ स्मार्ट पेंटेस्टर्स क्या होते
हैं जो प्रोफेशनल पेंटेस्टर्स हैं जिनको
पता है जिनके पास कुछ एक्सपीरियंस है कि
पेन टेस्टिंग का। वह क्या करते हैं कि ऐसी
चीजें पहले ही अपने एग्रीमेंट में जब
रूल्स ऑफ इंगेजमेंट साइन होता है जो उनका
कॉन्ट्रैक्ट साइन होता है वो क्या करते
हैं पहले ही ऐसी चीजें क्या करते हैं
एग्रीमेंट में लिख लेते हैं वो इस तरीके
से लिखते हैं कि फॉर एग्जांपल ऐसे लिखा कि
अगर आपने अपने एंप्लॉय को सही तरीके से
ट्रेन नहीं किया उन्हें अगर साइबर के बारे
में सही से अवेयरनेस प्रोवाइड नहीं की और
सही से ट्रेनिंग नहीं दी तो सिक्योरिटी
मिस स्टेप्स के लिए या सिक्योरिटी लूप
होल्स के लिए या सिक्योरिटी गैप्स के लिए
आप उन्हें फायर नहीं कर सकते। इस तरीके के
टर्म्स एंड कंडीशन आप क्या कर सकते हो? उस
कॉन्ट्रैक्ट में पहले से ही मेंशन करोगे।
तो यह पहले से मेंशन कब कर पाओगे? जब आपको
पेन टेस्टिंग का एक्सपीरियंस होगा। आप जब
फर्स्ट टाइम पेन टेस्टिंग कर रहे होंगे।
पहली बात तो आप ऐसे कर आपको करने को
मिलेगी नहीं। क्योंकि आपके पास
एक्सपीरियंस तभी यह कर पाओगे। वरना विदाउट
एक्सपीरियंस ये चीज आप करनी पड़ पाओगे कर
पाओगे। इसलिए मैं आपको बता रहा था कि
क्योंकि यह चीज आपको एक्सपीरियंस के साथ
आएगी क्योंकि आपको पता है कि जब मैं पेन
टेस्टिंग रिपोर्ट सबमिट करूंगा उसके
क्या-क्या नेगेटिव इफेक्ट हो सकते हैं।
किस-किस पे प्रॉब्लम क्रिएट हो सकती है।
किस-किस पे गाज गिर सकती है। यह सारी
चीजें सर नेगेटिव सरकमस्ट्ससेस होते हैं।
इसीलिए आप क्या करते हो? पहले ही
कॉन्ट्रैक्ट में क्या करोगे? एक छोटी सी
लाइन ऐड कर दोगे। और जब एंप्लई ऐसी डिटेल
मांगेगा आप उसको कॉन्ट्रैक्ट दिखाओगे।
भैया मैंने लिखा था साफसाफ अगर आपने
एमंप्लई को सही से ट्रेन नहीं किया है
कंपनी के सही तरह उसकी ट्रेनिंग में
कमियां है तो आप उसको एंप्लॉयड को फायर
नहीं कर सकते और इसके अकॉर्डिंग अगर आप
एग्री करते हो तभी मैं आपको डिटेल दूंगा।
अदरवाइज मैं आपको डिटेल नहीं दूंगा। समझ
में आया यह चीज आपको?
समझ में आया आपको यह चीज?
अंडरस्टुड एवरीवन?
क्योंकि
सोशल इंजीनियरिंग टेस्ट करने का मतलब मेन
मोटो क्या है? जो एंप्लाइज हैं जो वहां पर
काम करते हैं उनको सही रास्ता दिखाना ना
कि उनका करियर खत्म कर देना। उनकी जॉब छीन
लेना। यह सोशल इंजीनियरिंग टेस्टिंग का
मतलब नहीं है। आपका काम है उनको सही
रास्ता दिखाना। ठीक है? अब इसके अपोजिट एक
फ्लिप्ड वर्जन भी है। फ्लिप्ड वर्जन क्या
है? कि अगर कोई एंप्लई आपकी फिसिंग ईमेल
को कैच करता है, पकड़ता है, आपके फेक कॉल
को पकड़ लेता है, आइडेंटिफाई कर लेता है,
आपकी इंगेजमेंट को फेल कर देता है, तो उन
लोगों का नाम रिपोर्ट में होना चाहिए।
जिन लोगों जिन पर फिशिंग हुई जो बकरे बन
गए जो फंस गए उन लोगों का नाम नहीं होना
चाहिए। उनकी उनकी उनकी एनोनिमसी मेंटेन
करनी है। लेकिन जिन लोगों ने इस अटैक को
प्रोटेक्ट किया है, डिटेक्ट किया है, आपके
अटैक को फेल किया है, उन लोगों को क्या
है? उन लोगों का नाम रिपोर्ट में 100%
होना चाहिए। क्योंकि उन लोगों ने सही
मायने में अपनी ड्यूटी की है। सही
ट्रेनिंग थी। उन्होंने क्या किया है? एज ए
एक ह्यूमन फायर वाल बनकर उस कंपनी को
प्रोटेक्ट किया है। मतलब एक फायर वाल के
रूप में उस कंपनी को प्रोटेक्ट किया है।
और
जब यह रिपोर्टिंग हो आप मेक श्योर करें या
आप उनको बताएं कंपनी को कि उन्हें पब्लिक
पब्लिकली रिवॉर्ड मिलना चाहिए। कोई छोटा
सा एप्रिसिएशन हो गया, कोई एप्रिसिएशन
बोनस हो गया, कोई सर्टिफिकेट हो गया। मतलब
कहने का मतलब क्या है कि आपको जिसने भी
डिटेक्ट किया है, जिसने एज ए फायर वाइल
काम किया है, आपके अटैक को फेल किया है,
उनका नाम रिपोर्ट में हाईलाइट करो। उसके
बाद उनको रिकॉग्नाइज करो। कोई छोटा सा
एप्रिसिएशन दिलवाओ, कोई रिवार्ड दिलवाओ,
सबके सामने तालियां बजवाओ। इससे क्या
होगा?
इससे क्या होगा? जो टीम होती है टीम में
मोटिवेशन आता है। वह हाईली मोटिवेट होते
हैं। उनको मोटिवेशन मिलता है। उनको सीख
मिलती है। उनको पता चलता है कि बाकी
एंप्लई क्या सोचेंगे यह देखकर कि
सिक्योरिटी रिपोर्ट करने पर रिवार्ड मिलता
है। कि अगर वह कंपनी को प्रोटेक्ट करते
हैं, सही से काम करते हैं अपना काम और वह
सही से सारी चीजें ढंग से रिपोर्ट करते
हैं तो उनको रिवार्ड भी मिलता है और
रिवार्ड के पीछे लोग काम भी करते हैं,
मोटिवेट होते हैं। एक दूसरे से सीखते भी
हैं। इससे क्या होगा? जो सिक्योरिटी कल्चर
है आपका पहले से ज्यादा स्ट्रांग हो
जाएगा।
ठीक है? वह पहले से ज्यादा स्ट्रांग हो
जाएगा। अंडरस्टुड एवरीवन कि
अगर
जो फंस गया उसको बचाना है और जिन्होंने
आपको पकड़ा है उनको रिवॉर्ड दिलवाना है।
सीधी सी बात है। सिंपल सी बात है।
अंडरस्टुड एवरीवन? यह थी किसकी? आपकी
स्टेप कौन सा स्टेप था? डी ब्रीफिंग स्टेप
का। यह आपकी डी ब्रीफ रिपोर्ट होगी।
नेक्स्ट अगर हम बात करें मैनेजमेंट की
रिस्पांसिबिलिटी।
ठीक है? देखो इंगेजमेंट खत्म हो गया।
ठीक है? अब इंगेजमेंट खत्म होने के बाद
हैकर की नहीं बल्कि मैनेजमेंट की भी एक
बहुत बड़ी रिस्पांसिबिलिटी होती है। वो
मैनेजमेंट की रिसोंसिबिलिटी क्या होती है?
जैसे ही टेस्टिंग खत्म हुई मैनेजमेंट को
क्या करना है? अपने एंप्लई के साथ एक
ट्रांसपेरेंसी मेंटेन करनी है। अपने
एंप्लई के साथ बातचीत करनी है। उनको एक
जगह इकट्ठा इकट्ठा करना है। उनके साथ
मीटिंग करनी है और उनको क्लियर करना है कि
कंपनी खुद से उनकी कोई जासूसी नहीं कर रही
थी। उन्हें टारगेट नहीं कर रही थी।
ठीक है? उनको बताना है कि हमने क्या किया
है? किसी एक थर्ड पार्टी साइबर सिक्योरिटी
फर्म को पे किया है। कोई भी एक थर्ड
पार्टी फॉर एग्जांपल यह हो सकते हैं। देखो
यह तीन यह हो सकते हैं कि हमने कोई एक
थर्ड पार्टी सर्विस थी उनको पेमेंट की।
उनसे हमने क्या किया है? हमने टेस्टिंग
करवाई है। और यह टेस्टिंग हमने क्यों
करवाई है? हमें यह पता करना था कि जो
हमारी कंपनी है उसमें क्या-क्या कमियां
थी। कमियां ढूंढ लेंगे हमने। वो टेस्टिंग
करवाई है और हमारे पास आपकी कोई भी पर्सनल
डाटा कोई भी पर्सनल इंफॉर्मेशन नहीं है।
हमें जो डाटा है हमें जो डाटा मिला है और
हमने जो डाटा कलेक्ट किया है वह सिर्फ
बिजनेस सिक्योरिटी से रिलेटेड डाटा हमने
कलेक्ट किया है या जो बिजनेस सिक्योरिटी
है जो हमारी कंपनी की सिक्योरिटी है उससे
रिलेटेड डाटा ही हमने अपने पास रखा है।
बाकी आपकी जो पर्सनल लाइफ है आपकी जो
प्राइवेसी है वह बिल्कुल सेफ है। उससे
रिलेटेड हमने आपका कोई भी पर्सनल डाटा
अपने पास नहीं रखा है। ना ही हमने थर्ड
पार्टी साइबर सिक्योरिटी टीम को को दिया
है। ना इसकी कोई परमिशन दी गई है। मतलब जब
आपकी मैनेजमेंट
आपके साथ इस तरह की ट्रांसपेरेंसी मेंटेन
करती है। सारी चीजें क्लियर करती है। इससे
क्या होता है? जो एमंप्लॉय हैं वहां पर जो
काम करते हैं उनका जो डर था कि कहीं पर
मेरी किसी कुछ हो सकती है कोई ऐसी पर्सनल
इंफॉर्मेशन हो जिससे वो डर रहे हो उसका डर
खत्म हो जाएगा। दूसरी चीज क्या होगी कि जो
एंप्लई है उनका ट्रस्ट बनेगा। वो आप पर
ज्यादा ट्रस्ट करेंगे। उस ऑर्गेनाइजेशन से
रिलेटेड पे ज्यादा ट्रस्ट करेंगे। उनको
पता चलेगा कि ओके जो मैनेजमेंट है वह हम
पर विश्वास करती है। वह भी मैनेजमेंट पर
विश्वास करेंगे। मतलब जो मैनेजमेंट टीम है
जो वर्किंग टीम है उन सबके बीच में क्या
रहेगी? एक कोऑर्डिनेशन रहेगा। एक
मोटिवेटेड टीम रहेगी। मतलब एक दूसरे पर
ट्रस्ट रहेगा और वहां पर जहां पर ट्रस्ट
होता है वहां पर काम बहुत ज्यादा अच्छे से
होता है। ठीक है? यह थी आपकी
मैनेजमेंट की रिस्पांसिबिलिटी। देन उसके
बाद बात करें जो असेसमेंट रिपोर्ट आप में
आपने सबमिट की है उस रिपोर्ट को एज ए
ट्रेनिंग मटेरियल यूज किया जाना चाहिए
ताकि जो पूरी कंपनी है जो पूरी
ऑर्गेनाइजेशन है वह एक साथ सिक्योर रहे
क्योंकि उसमें क्या है असेसमेंट की
फाइंडिंग है लेसन क्या-क्या हमें करना है
क्या-क्या नहीं करना चाहिए एंप्लई की
ट्रेनिंग कहां कैसी होनी चाहिए क्या-क्या
पॉलिसी इंप्रूवमेंट होनी चाहिए क्या-क्या
सिक्योरिटी कल्चर फॉलो होना चाहिए
क्या-क्या इंप्रूवमेंट होने चाहिए वो सारी
चीजें उस रिपोर्ट में डिटेल्स मेंशन होती
है। क्या-क्या गलतियां थी, क्या-क्या
इंफॉर्मेशन मिले थी, क्या चीज ध्यान में
रखनी है, क्या चीज ध्यान में नहीं रखनी
है, यह सारी चीज उस रिपोर्ट्स में होती
है। और उसको क्या करना है? एज ए ट्रेनिंग
मटेरियल सबके साथ शेयर करना है ताकि आपके
जो एंप्लॉय है, आपके जो टीम्स हैं, सब लोग
क्या कर पाए, अवेयर रहें। उनको पता रहे कि
क्या-क्या करना है और क्या नहीं करना है।
क्या करना है और क्या नहीं करना है। वह
सारी चीजें उस टीम को पता रहे। अंडरस्टुड?
और सबसे बड़ी बात एक और चीज बताता हूं कि
जब भी आप किसी भी ग्लोबल कॉन्फ्रेंसेस में
जाओगे। ठीक है? या किसी कहीं पर आप ग्लोबल
कॉन्फ्रेंस करते हो मतलब कहीं पर आप क्या
करते हो? किसी इंटरनेशनल साइबर सिक्योरिटी
कॉन्फ्रेंस में जाते हो तो वहां पर भी
आपको क्या करना है? आपके एथिक्स को मेंटेन
करना है। इसका मतलब यह नहीं है कि आपने
कंपनी की पेंट टेस्टिंग की, उस कॉर्पोरेट
की पेंट टेस्टिंग की और जो एथिक्स की हमने
बात की
हमने एंप्लई के प्राइवेसी की बात की वो
सिर्फ उस कंपनी तक लिमिटेड थी। नहीं आप
कहीं पर भी उन सब चीजों का जिक्र करोगे
किसी भी कॉन्फ्रेंस में किसी भी ग्लोबल
कॉन्फ्रेंस में किसी कॉलेज में कहीं पर भी
आप मीट अप करोगे कहीं पर वो इंफॉर्मेशन
शेयर करने की कोशिश करोगे या रियल वर्ल्ड
केसेस बताने की कोशिश करोगे तब भी आपको
क्या करना है आपको वह सारे एथिक्स रूल्स
फॉलो करने हैं। सोचिए कि आप स्टेज पर खड़े
होकर किसी लाइव केस स्टडी को बता रहे हो।
ठीक है? और क्या कर रहे हो? विक्टिम का
मजाक उड़ा रहे हो। और हो सकता है कि वो
विक्टिम वहां पर प्रेजेंट हो। हो सकता है
ना वो विक्टिम वहां पर प्रेजेंट हो। ठीक
है? और वहां पर उसके सामने या क्या कर रहे
हो कि उसका मजाक उड़ाया जा रहा है। आप हंस
रहे हैं, लोग हंस रहे हैं। इससे क्या
होगा? इससे वो क्या समझेगा? आपको
अनप्रोफेशनल समझेगा। ठीक है? आपकी जो
क्रेडिबिलिटी है
मतलब आप अपने आप को मानते हो कि मैं बहुत
अच्छा काम कर रहा हूं बट उसके लिए आप
अच्छा काम नहीं कर रहे आपकी क्रेडिबिलिटी
बिल्कुल हो जाएगी जीरो इसीलिए आपको क्या
करना है हमेशा ध्यान रखना है किसी भी
मीटिंग में कहीं पर भी आप एग्जांपल तो हम
देते हैं हमें आदत होती है कि हमने वहां
पर पेन टेस्टिंग की थी इस तरीके से पे
टेस्टिंग की थी और यह कमियां मिली थी वहां
पर भी आपको क्या करना है आपका डेकोरम
मेंटेन करना है आपकी इंटीग्रिटी मेंटेन
करनी आपको वहां पर भी पब्लिकली उस एंप्लॉय
को जिस एंप्लई ने वह गलती की थी उसको
पब्लिकली एक्सपोज नहीं करना है। बिकॉज़ यू
डोंट नो वो आप में प्रेजेंट है या नहीं
प्रेजेंट है। आपको उसका मजाक नहीं उड़ाना
है। आपको हमेशा आपके एथिक्स, आपके रूल्स
आपको हमेशा याद रखने हैं। उनको छोड़ना
नहीं है।
नेक्स्ट
साइबर सिक्योरिटी का एक गोल्डन रूल होता
है।
प्रेज इन पब्लिक
रिप्रे रिपमेंट इन प्राइवेट मतलब मतलब यह
है तारीफ सबके सामने करो
लेकिन
पनिशमेंट
डांट फटकार या समझौता हमेशा अकेले में
करो।
कहने का मतलब क्या है कि फॉर एग्जांपल अगर
किसी ने आपके अटैक को पकड़ लिया तो पूरी
कंपनी के सामने अनाउंस करो। पूरी कंपनी के
सामने उसको बुलाकर रिवार्ड दिलवाओ। उसके
लिए तालियां बजवाओ। पूरी कंपनी को बताओ।
लेकिन वहीं पर किसी अगर एंप्लई ने गलती की
है, वह आपके अटैक में फंसा है तो उसको
अकेले में बैठाकर समझाना है, ट्रेनिंग
देनी है, बताना है। आपकी क्या गलती थी?
आपको क्या नहीं करना चाहिए था? क्योंकि
एथिकल हैकिंग का असली मेन गोल क्या है?
किसी को नीचा दिखाना नहीं है। किसी को डी
डीमोटिवेट करना नहीं है। किसी को परेशान
करना नहीं है। बल्कि सबको प्रोटेक्ट करना
है। एथिकल हैकिंग का मतलब ही यह है सबको
प्रोटेक्ट करना है। ना कि किसी को
डीमोटिवेट, किसी को
क्या करना?
पर्सनली हर्ट करना। यह आपका काम नहीं है।
तो, यहां तक सबको समझ में आया?
यहां तक सबको सब कुछ क्लियर है
बताओ
एक बार बता दीजिए उसके बाद हम आज के क्लास
का लास्ट और सबसे इंटरेस्टिंग सबसे डेंजर
रियल वर्ल्ड के स्टडी करने वाले हैं।
अभी तो रेगुलर क्लास आ रही है। अभिषेक
एव्री सैटरडे और संडे क्लास हो रही है।
दोनों दिन
प्लीज एक बार सब लोग बता दीजिए। एक या दो
स्टूडेंट ने अभी आंसर किया है। सबको
क्लियर है? तभी हम वह केस स्टडी डिस्कस
करने वाले हैं।
अभिषेक भाई मेरे को भी टाइम नहीं मिलता
यार मंडे टू फ्राइडे आई एम वेरी वेरीरी
बिजी
चलिए फिर तो अभी हम क्या करने वाले हैं?
एक ऐसे रियल वर्ल्ड के स्टडी को स्टडी
करने वाले हैं, डिस्कस करने वाले हैं जो
यह प्रूव करती है कि अगर सोशल इंजीनियरिंग
अपनी लिमिट क्रॉस कर दे
जो सोशल इंजीनियरिंग की लिमिट है जो
एथिक्स है अगर उनको क्रॉस कर दे
तो कितनी बड़ी ट्रेजडी हो सकती है उसके
बारे में बात कर सकता हूं।
कितनी बड़ी ट्रेजडी कितनी बड़ी घटना घट
सकती है उसके बारे में बात करने वाले हैं।
यह इंसिडेंट है।
2012 का 2012 का यह इंसिडेंट है। 2012 में
ऐसा क्या हुआ था? 2012 में ऐसा हुआ था कि
यह फैक्ट है। मैं कुछ ओरिजिनल नाम नहीं
लेने वाला। बस एक ऑस्ट्रेलिया का केस है।
यह 2012 में हुआ क्या? अभी नहीं मिलेगा
क्योंकि यह सब कुछ क्या कर दिया? हटा दिया
गया है। बस यह मैं यह केस एक किसी बुक से
लिया है। मैंने बुक से जब मैं पढ़ रहा था
मैंने पता चला था। बुक्स में था ये केस।
केस यह था कि एक बहुत बड़े घर से कि एक
औरत थी प्रेग्नेंट थी। उनको कुछ एक
प्रॉब्लम हुई, कोई होम सिकनेस हुई, कुछ
एक्सट्रीम क्रिटिकल कंडीशंस हुई और वो
क्या गई? हॉस्पिटल में एडमिट हो गई। ठीक
है? अब रिच फैमिली से थी, किसी रॉयल
फैमिली से थी तो वह हो गई क्या हो गई?
एडमिट हो गई। अब वहीं पर क्या होता है कि
अराउंड मॉर्निंग में
दो डीजे डीजे आपको पता ही है जो प्रैंक
करते हैं। टू डीजे फ्रॉम ऑस्ट्रेलियन
रेडियो शो उन्होंने अपनी आवाज को बदला और
अपना नाम बताया। एक ने क्वीन ऑफ इंग्लैंड
दूसरे ने बताया अपना प्रिंस चार्लेज। मतलब
दोनों ने अपना नाम भी बदल लिया और किसी और
दूसरे का कैरेक्टर प्ले करने लगे। और
अर्ली मॉर्निंग अराउंड 5:30 उन्होंने कॉल
किया हॉस्पिटल में। ठीक है? उस पर्टिकुलर
हॉस्पिटल में कॉल किया। हॉस्पिटल में फोन
उठाया एक नर्स ने रिसेप्शन पे। रिसेप्शन
पे उन्होंने एक नर्स ने फोन उठाया और नर्स
ने फोन उठाने पर उसने बताया। उन्होंने
क्या बताया कि मैं क्वीन ऑफ इंग्लैंड और
एक ने बताया मैं प्रिंस चार्लेस बट
एक्टिंग करने लगे। उसको मैंने उससे बातचीत
करने लगे। और जो नर्स थी
उसको उनके ऊपर शक नहीं क्योंकि उनका जो
प्रीक्स्ट था और उसका जो स्टोरी थी वो
इतनी रियल थी कि उनको शक नहीं हुआ। उनको
सच में लगा कि ओके यह कोई रॉयल फैमिली के
से ही कॉल कर रहे हैं। उनके बारे में क्या
करने की कोशिश कर रहे हैं? उनके
जो चिंता है कि उनकी जो हेल्थ अपडेट लेने
के बारे में कोशिश कोशिश कर रहे हैं। उनकी
हेल्थ जानकारी लेना चाहते हैं। तो उसने
क्या कर दिया? कि जो लेडीज आपके एडमिट थी
उसकी जो पर्सनल नर्स थी उसको कॉल ट्रांसफर
कर दिया। उन्होंने क्या कर दिया? कॉल
ट्रांसफर कर दिया। बता दिया कि सोन सो
इनके फैमिली फ्रेंड या जो भी है उनका नाम
बताया कि क्वीन ऑफ इंग्लैंड है या प्रिंस
चार्लेस हैं। उन्होंने कॉल किया है। तो
उनसे कनेक्ट करवा दिया। अब जो उसकी जो
नर्स थी उसके पास थी। उसने क्या किया?
बिना किसी सोचे समझे उसने सब कुछ क्या कर
दिया? जो भी मेडिकल इंफॉर्मेशन थी सारी की
सारी इंफॉर्मेशन
उस लेडी की शेयर कर दी उन दोनों डिजीज के
सामने। ठीक है? उन जो जो दोनों डिजीज थी
उसके सामने उन्होंने क्या कर दिया? वह
सारी की सारी इंफॉर्मेशन शेयर कर दी। अब
यहां तक आपको लगता है इसमें कुछ भी गलत
नहीं है। और हालांकि यह दोनों प्रैंक कर
रहे थे।
नाम बदलकर यह
अपनी पब्लिसिटी के लिए प्रैंक कर रहे थे,
इंफॉर्मेशन ले रहे थे और यहां तक कुछ गलत
भी नहीं था। गलत कब हुआ? उन्होंने क्या
किया? उन्होंने वह चीज रिकॉर्ड कर ली।
उन्होंने ये चीज रिकॉर्ड की। रिकॉर्ड करके
अपने शो के ऊपर ऑन एयर कर दिया। ऑन एयर
मतलब पूरी दुनिया में ब्रॉडकास्ट कर दिया।
रिकॉर्डिंग की। रिकॉर्डिंग करके उन्होंने
उसको प्ले कर दिया और पूरी दुनिया में उस
रिकॉर्डिंग को ब्रॉडकास्ट कर दिया। पूरी
दुनिया में ब्रॉडकास्ट कर दिया।
ठीक है? जिससे क्या हुआ? उसको इंटरनेशनल
अटेंशन मिली। क्योंकि वह एक
रॉयल फैमिली से थी। तो इंटरनेशनल
उसको बोलते हैं इंटरनेशनल अटेंशन तो मिलनी
ही थी। तब उन्होंने यह कर दिया आप चाहे
उनका प्रग समझो चाहे उनका कुछ भी समझो ठीक
है अब उसके क्सिक्वेंसेस क्या हुए
कंसक्वेंसेस क्या थे कि हॉस्पिटल कोई
एक्शन लेता जो नर्स थी जिस नर्स ने उसको
कॉल फॉरवर्ड की थी यह वाली जो नर्स थी इस
नर्स के ऊपर हॉस्पिटल कोई एक्शन लेता
एक्शन लेने से पहले ही उस नर्स ने क्या कर
लिया सुसाइड कर लिया
उसने सुसाइड कर लिया।
समझ रहे हो?
फिर से बता रहा हूं। उन्होंने सुसाइड कर
लिया क्योंकि वो शर्मिंदगीगी और वह प्रेशर
वो झेल नहीं पाई।
ठीक है? उस प्रेशर और शर्मिंदगीगी के कारण
उसने क्या कर लिया?
अपनी जान ले ली। इनका मजाक था, प्रैंक था।
और किसी की जिंदगी चली गई।
ठीक है? उसके बाद हुआ क्या? जो रॉयल
फैमिली थी उन्होंने एक कंडोलेंस मैसेज
रिलीज किया। रेडियो शो कैंसिल हो गया।
सारी चीजें डिलीट कर दी गई। और जो ये
दोनों इनका Twitter अकाउंट इनकी जो
प्रॉब्लम थी सब कुछ ब्लॉक किया गया। सब
कुछ डिलीट किया गया। इन्होंने पब्लिकली
माफी मांग ली। लेकिन जब इन्होंने पब्लिकली
माफी मांगी
तब तक वह बहुत लेट हो चुके थे।
तब तक वह बहुत लेट हो चुके थे। क्योंकि
अकॉर्डिंग टू एपीए एनालिसिस अमेरिकन
साइकोलॉजिकल एसोसिएशन एनालिसिस। दिस वाज
प्योर मैनपुलेशन बिकॉज़ द डीजी इंटेंशन वाज
नॉट टू हेल्प एनीवन बट फॉर चीप पॉपुलरिटी।
मतलब
उनका मकसद किसी का भला करना नहीं था।
सिर्फ एक सस्ती पॉपुलरिटी के लिए, एक
सस्ती टीआरपी के लिए, अपने आप को पॉपुलर
करने के लिए, अपने चैनल को पॉपुलर करने के
लिए
उन्होंने यह किया था। एनालिसिस रिपोर्ट यह
थी। उनका कहना यह था। लेकिन अगर सोचो जब
उन्होंने फर्स्ट टाइम कॉल किया और कॉल के
दौरान वो बता देते कि हम मजाक कर रहे हैं।
ठीक है? हम प्रैंक कर रहे हैं
तो यह नहीं होता। यह नर्स जिंदा होती या
शायद यहां तक स्टेप टू कर लिया था।
इंफॉर्मेशन मिल गई थी। अगर उसको
ब्रॉडकास्ट ना करते उसको इंटरनेशनल न्यूज़
नहीं बनाते।
तब तक भी कुछ नहीं हुआ था।
तब तक भी कुछ नहीं हुआ था। तब भी वह आज एक
वो नर्स
उन सबके बीच में होती। बट
इनकी सस्ती पॉपुलरिटी इनकी टीआरपी,
इनकी गलतियां जहां पे ये रूल्स, एथिक्स सब
कुछ भूल गए थे। सिर्फ अपने आप को पॉपुलर
करने के लिए इन्होंने उस नर्स के बारे में
सोचा जिसने कॉल फॉरवर्ड की थी।
ठीक है? ना उस लेडीज के बारे में सोचा
जिसके बारे में प्रैंक किया गया था जिसकी
इंफॉर्मेशन लीक की गई थी। किसी के बारे
में नहीं सोचा। सारे एथिक्स, सारे रूल्स
सब कुछ तोड़ दिए।
इनका कुछ हुआ नहीं।
किसी का पर्सनल लॉस हो गया। सोच रहे हो कि
अगर एक सोशल इंजीनियरिंग टेक्निक जब अपनी
हद पार कर दे
तो वह इस तरह का रूप ले सकती है। इस तरह
के भयानक हादसे क्रिएट कर सकती है। इस तरह
के भयानक हादसे होते हैं। सोशल
इंजीनियरिंग के कारण
हमें चीजें नॉर्मल लगती हैं।
मैं बोलता हूं इस तरह की चीजें एथिक्स
लीगल कंसीडरेशंस
लीगलिटी नॉन लीगटी
क्या गलत है क्या सही है पेन टेस्टिंग में
जरूर पढ़ाना चाहिए इसीलिए मैं यह दो
क्लासेस लेकर आया आपके सामने कि आप जो कर
रहे हो कितनी सीरियस चीज कर रहे हो आपका
एक गलत कदम
किसी को कहीं पर भी ले जा सकता है
इसलिए हमेशा हमेशा याद रखिए सोशल
इंजीनियरिंग में एक इंसान है। ठीक है? कोई
मशीन नहीं है। मशीन के साथ मजाक कर सकते
हो। कोई प्रॉब्लम नहीं होगा।
ठीक है? लेकिन इंसान है। वहां पर आपके जो
एथिक्स है आपकी जो एमथी है वो हमेशा आपकी
टॉप प्रायोरिटी होनी चाहिए। आपके जो
एथिक्स जो एमथी है आपकी टॉप प्रायोरिटी
होनी चाहिए। इसीलिए
हमने दो लेक्चर्स में क्या कवर किया कि
हमने क्या सीखा कि हमें हमेशा एनोनिमस
रिपोर्ट करनी है। हमें हमेशा एनोनिमिटी को
ध्यान में रखना है। हमेशा यह ध्यान रखना
है अच्छे लोगों को रिवार्ड मिलना चाहिए।
हमारी टेस्टिंग की वजह से किसी की सेल्फ
रिस्पेक्ट पर आंच नहीं आनी चाहिए। किसी की
सेल्फ रिस्पेक्ट कम नहीं होनी चाहिए। किसी
का पर्सनल लॉस नहीं होना चाहिए।
अंडरस्टुड एवरीवन?
थोड़ा मैं भी भावुक हो गया था। बिकॉज़ इट इज
अ वेरी वेरी सीवियर
इंसिडेंट जो एक कुछ ना समझो की वजह से हो
गया।
ओके
अंडरस्टुड एवरीवन?
सबको मजा आया? क्लासेस अच्छी लगी
कुछ सीखने को मिला
अभय पूछ रहे हैं सर मैं क्या करूंगा कि
मेरा सोशल मीडिया गेट हैक रिपोर्ट करो
साइबर क्राइम में बस रिपोर्ट करो आप अपनी
तरफ से कुछ इललीगल मत करो
अंडरस्टुड एवरीवन सबको समझ में आया क्लास
में मेरे ख्याल से एक
मेरे ख्याल से सबको सारी चीजें क्लियर
होंगी अगर किसी को कोई भी डाउट है।
हां अभिषेक नोट्स मैं याद दिलाता हूं सर
को क्योंकि आज की क्लास फिनिश होगी तो आज
की क्लास के प्रीवियस क्लास के जो 60 से
लेके नोट्स को अपलोड करवाता हूं और पुराने
नोट्स को मैं एक-एक करके अभी कलेक्ट कर
रहा हूं। मैंने पता नहीं कहां-कहां से
नोट्स बना के आपको पढ़ाए थे। नोट्स को मैं
फाइंड आउट कर रहा हूं।
और वह जल्दी वो भी एप्लीकेशनेशंस पे
होंगे। तो आई होप सबको सारी चीजें क्लियर
होगी। किसी का कोई भी डाउट है रिलेटेड टू
द सेशन प्रीवियस क्लासेस से रिलेटेड तो
मुझसे पूछ सकता है।
किसी का कोई भी डाउट है मुझसे पूछ सकता
है।
आपको कैसे पता चला आप हैक हो गए? पहली बात
तो
सर मैं आज ही आया हूं। बस मुझे एन मैप यूज़
करना आता है। तो क्या करूंगा? एडवांस
हैकिंग करनी है।
मुझे यह बताएं अभय
आपको एडवांस हैकिंग का मतलब क्या होता है?
यह बताओ।
अभिषेक ओके आई विल ट्राई मैं आप लोगों के
लिए यह भी चीज सोच रहा हूं
मुझे आप लोगों के लिए एक बेस्ट बुक फाइंड
आउट करने की कोशिश कर रहा हूं या बेस्ट
क्वेश्चंस जो ज्यादातर
यूज किए जाते हैं तो उस पर डिस्कशन करना
स्टार्ट करेंगे
मेरे दिमाग में है बट सारी चीजें एक साथ
नहीं लेके आ सकता बिकॉज़ आई एम ए वर्किंग
पर्सन तो मेरी भी लिमिटेशंस हैं क्योंकि
एक सिस्टम्स होता है ना एक एक सिस्टम्स
हमेशा काम करता रहता है तो उसकी एक लिमिट
होती है तो आई हैव आल्सो ए लिमिट तो लेकिन
धीरे-धीरे मैं सारी चीजें कोशिश कर रहा
हूं
आई विल ट्राई माय बेस्ट आप लोगों के लिए
जितना अच्छा मैं प्रोवाइड कर सकता हूं
जितनी अच्छा चीजें मैं आपको बता सकता हूं
वो सब
एक चीज बताता हूं दोस्तों आप जो बोल रहे
हो ना कि आई वांट टू मेक अ करियर इन साइबर
एग्जीक्यूटिव टू स्टॉप थिंग्स लाइक पेपर
लीक्स सच बोलूं यू कांट डू एनीथिंग
यू कांट डू एनीथिंग अगेंस्ट ए सिस्टम
दिस इज अ रियलिटी एक कड़वा सच है आप कुछ
नहीं कर सकते मुंह पर बोल रहा हूं पर सच
है
आप सिस्टम से नहीं लड़ सकते
ऐसे सिस्टम से
जो बहुत ज्यादा पावरफुल है
बिल्कुल एग्जैक्ट
तब भी नहीं कर सकते आप
तो इन फालतू की चीजों से मोटिवेट होना बंद
करो
फोकस करो आप अपने आप को कैसे बचा सकते हो?
बस सेफ योर साइड। आप अपने आप को बचाओ।
खुद बुरा मत करो।
जितना स्टॉप कर सकते हो अपनी आंखों के
सामने वो करने की कोशिश करो।
समझ रहे हो?
जो आपके हाथ में वह करने की कोशिश करो। जो
हाथ में नहीं है वह करने जाओगे। जो हाथ
में आने वाला था वह भी चला जाएगा।
अंडरस्टुड एवरीवन
कुछ चीजें कड़वी होती है
बस सच होती हैं
और मेरे से बैठे सिस्टम को कोई नहीं जानता
होगा।
चलिए फिर किसी को कोई डाउट है तो बताओ।
डाउट नहीं है तो सेशन को एंड करते हैं।
अननेसेसरी आपका भी टाइम वेस्ट नहीं होगा।
कोई डाउट है क्लास
कोई भी डाउट है
नो बाकी
बाकी लोग
भाई जगत गुरु जी खतरनाक इंग्लिश लिखते हो
यार क्या मतलब मेरे को समझा दो मेरी
इंग्लिश थोड़ी सी वीक है
कहां से कॉपी करते हो
इतनी खतरनाक आती है
भाई कमजोर है आपके इंस्ट्रक्टर पढ़ाने
वाले आपके जो टीचर
आपको ज्ञान देने वाले आपके गुरु जी
बेचारों को इंग्लिश कम आती है यार।
चलो फिर सेशन को एंड करते हैं। फिर किसी
को कोई डाउट नहीं तो। एंड
ओके बाय-ब एवरीवन गुड नाइट एवरीवन एंड सी
यू बाद में हम मिलते हैं नेक्स्ट सैटरडे
और संडे नेक्स्ट नए एनर्जेटिक टॉपिक के
साथ नई एनर्जेटिक एनर्जी के साथ नई चीजों
के साथ तब तक के लिए गुड बाय एवरीवन टेक
केयर सीखते रहिए
इसमें तो कुछ यह भी नहीं बोल सकते कि जाओ
और प्रैक्टिस करो क्योंकि प्रैक्टिस करने
के लिए कुछ नहीं है। सब समझने के लिए था।
इंफॉर्मेशन थी बट जस्ट डिस्कशनंस थे जो
आपसे बात कर ली एंड थैंक यू गाइस एवरीवन
एंड बाय बाय गुड नाइट एवरीवन